real service all right sorry sorry so
sorry I just had to grab my wallet
fine I was trying something and it
didn't work
Salvatore Man 4 Lottie has been cutting
hair across from pioneer hall since 1958
all the movers and shakers who come
through Pawnee have sat in that chair at
one point or another he's the guy that
made Larry Bird look the way he does
next so what's the inside scoop
Salvatore my feet hurt ha ha classic
Salvatore the one don't you know this is
my first official political haircut I'm
Leslie Knope deputy director of Parks
and Recreation are you related to that
Marlene something nope that depends
would you call being her daughter
related the hell else would you call it
now what do you want me to do with this
well my mom is being honored tonight so
in a way I am also being honored and I
just wanted to mix things up a little
bit you know pin it up something sassy
but powerful and dynastic
hi April good evening sir no I'm off the
clock April you don't need to call me
sir
Salvatore calls this hairdo the mayor
and yes I will wear my hair like this
when I am the first female mayor of
Pawnee
I'm way overdressed
talking about you look great we look
great everyone's lookin at ya I know my
dream
yes I do very much want a drink that man
is staring that's a former city
councilman French novel oh we're in
rarified air tonight Anna rarefied air
he's coming over
what okay be cool be cold I will try
hello hello former city councilman I am
Leslie Knope I am the daughter of the
honoree this evening I just wanted to
tell you that I think that what you two
are doing is so brave and just being who
you are I wish I had your courage
are you wearing lady clothes what are
you wearing lady clothes those look like
lady pants no this is a Power Suit that
there's a woman suit I do not buy
women's clothes would not make that
mistake again
okay Pam would you please tell Darryl
that this is not a woman suit oh my god
that's a woman suit you're wearing a
woman suit no I do I I wear men's suits
okay I got this out of a bin there were
these huge bins of clothes and everybody
was rifling through them like crazy and
I grabbed one and it fit so I don't
think that this is totally just a woman
suit at the very least it's bisexual who
makes it mysterious it is mysterious
because the buttons are on the wrong
side that's the mystery okay would you
stop it please
Oh none of that tipped you off it's your
PIN okay it's a European cut Michael the
pants don't have any pockets no they
don't see Italians don't wear pockets
it's been a really rough couple of days
this helps a little hey maybe you want
to come over and read my closet no I
don't want to do that because I'm twice
your size anything yeah you look like
Hillary Clinton um let's just do this in
15 okay one second I got some emails so
what's this secret meeting all about you
guys know I'm not medically cleared for
another week it's not a secret meeting
Jake it's an intervention the tips have
to go what why Jake we're worried about
you and you look very stupid come on
guys I think they're kind of cool retro
no they're terrible Amy come on you're
digging the tips right no I feel like
I'm kissing vanilla ice there was a time
you would have jumped at that chance
yeah
to go all right you guys got me I did it
as a joke I kept them ironically pretty
funny right I'll admit it I went too
deep down there in Florida at one point
I think I forgot where the tip of me
ended and the base of the tips began
before we just chopped them off would
anybody like to say some final words no
that was one word that counts Thank You
Rosa okay I'm ready
sorry I'm late everyone but trust me
it's worth it
me and Jake are chip buds
[Applause]
[Music]
oh you know what I do see it it's mad it
looks bad okay
at number eight babe you look super hot
you realize you've said that about all
of them well she has every single time
cuz she is super hot honestly even look
hard naked well the suit makes me want
to scold a Catholic child I don't know
who Ann Taylor is but I hate her and I
want to kill her I have to lead a public
forum for the Pawnee Commons every day
this week and I hate talking to people
so to get through it I figured I'm just
gonna basically try to imitate Leslie
she still wears this she had the patch
sewn in you can't remove it what's in
the pocket you ask a ticket stub from a
Fleetwood Mac concert in 1995 and this
one is terrible but it is slightly less
terrible than the rest so tomorrow I
lead a public forum in Leslie's
Fleetwood Mac sex pants
it would Mac sex pants new band name I
call it whoo you know what maybe just
Fleetwood Mac it was so much more to
talk to this girl about you're both
salesmen I mean that's something right
there true plus I could talk to her
about the origins of my last name it's
all gold guys are usually my best
customers they buy the high-end stuff
with the beads and the sequins and stuff
Fergus you know they don't know what
they're looking at so I make suggestions
all right here's the thing
okay just keep talking to her if you hit
a stall you have a perfect ball back
what's that you buy a purse I don't want
a purse purses are for girls Dwight
that's not necessarily true okay do you
read GQ no okay I do
they're like mini briefcases all right
lots of guys have like those yes listen
you're spending way too much time
talking
okay I'm just gonna use the bathroom and
now I wanna don't need the bathroom
you've got it go this is going to be
good
hi my name is Dwight Schrute and I would
like to buy a purse from you
good lord look at these purses this is
something special
oh my god is this Salvatore Cheney us oh
definitely definitely step in and out of
it like that yes I want to stress test
it you know in case anything happened oh
that was really this is necessary to
really give a good workout
this is the oh this is the prettiest one
of all I'm gonna be the prettiest girl
in the bar oh how much oh it's sad it's
sad
number two Santiago and Boyle wore the
same outfit to work one day good morning
Jerry
that is a beautiful sweater vest April
you look like you could use $20 am i
right why cuz you're a kid and kids
always need money I need money ah that's
why you're my favorite Tom when Tiger
Woods feels invincible he wears a red
shirt and black pants good morning Ron
wears the same thing after he's had sex
I'm a simple man I like pretty
dark-haired women and breakfast food but
this stock photo I bought at a framing
store isn't real today I got the real
thing
a naked Tammy made me breakfast this
morning I should have taken a picture of
it they left for the big meeting yet I
got Michael's lucky tie no they're in
the conference room wait are those
Michaels Levi's yeah who dry-cleans
jeans Michael and his jeans he gets in
them and I'm not exactly sure what
happens but I can tell you he loves the
way he looks in those jeans I know
that's why he started casual Fridays
I'll take those Thanks
you